T
REVOLUTION".
PRO- WORKER PROFAMILY INFO
AMERICA ON THURSDAY BIDEN
CENTERS SOON TO BE TAX ADVISOR
TO CONGRESS TO TELL DEMOCRATS
HOW TO SELL HIS MASSIVE
UNPRECEDENTED EXPANSION OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE HAVE A
COPY THEY NOT ONLY REVEAL TO
TRANS INTO THE DISDAIN OF THAT
DECEPTION IN ORDER TO DO IT
BIDENS LYING IT STARTS ON THE
TITLE PAGE MORE JOBS TAX CUTS
LOWER COST RIGHT THERE THEY
ARE NOT CREATING JOBS THEY ARE
DESTROYING AND THEY ARE NOT
CUTTING TAXES THEY ARE RAISING
THEM HOW DO WE PAY FOR THAT?
TO WHICH THEY GIVE A TOTALLY
DISHONEST ANSWER THAT IS
ALIVE.
THE $400,000 IS FOR FAMILIES
NOT INDIVIDUALS IN FACT
EVERYONE MAKING $200,000 OR
MORE WOULD BE HIT BY DIRECT
TAX ID VENGEANCE ACTUALLY - -
EVEN JEN SAKI ADMITTED THAT.
THAT IS 100 PERCENT FALSE.
THE BIGGEST IMPACT IS FROM
INDIRECT TAX RISES BIDEN
CLAIMS WILL ONLY HAD LARGE
CORPORATIONS THAT HAVE WORKERS
OR SUPPLIERS OR CUSTOMERS.
IF YOU TAKE MORE MONEY THEN
GUESS WHAT AND PRICES ARE
HIGHER IT ALL HURTS THE MIDDLE
CLASS IT HAS BEEN ESTIMATED
WHAT IS THERE IS HALF THE
BURDEN OF CORPORATE TAX
INCREASES HELLO DEMOCRATS YOU
ED ON - - YOU IDIOTS IT IS
NEARLY HALF OF WORKING-CLASS
FAMILIES OR SHAREHOLDERS ON
TOP OF THAT THE DESTRUCTIVE
DEMOCRATIC TAX HIKES WOULD
COST GDP NORTH OF 8 PERCENT.
AND WITH TWO.1 PERCENT.
AND OF $650 A DIFFERENCE.
EVEN THE DEMOCRATS THEY HAVE
SHOWN YOU BEFORE SO THIS OF
THE OBAMA YEARS BUT WITH THE
TRUMP PROGRAM WITH POLICY
BLUE-COLLAR BOOTS GIVE THE
AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD INCOME GAINS
OF OVER $5000 A YEAR THAT
BIDEN ANTI- GROWTH AGENDA IS
MUCH MORE EXTREME EVEN THAN
OBAMA'S IT'S $4000 PER YEAR
LESSON BIDEN THINKS THAT TAX
CREDITS WILL COMPENSATE?
LOTS ONE - - LET'S LOOK AT
THOSE.
IT 60 PERCENT IS FRAMED AS A
TAX CUT IF YOU TOTALLY LIE
ABOUT IT AND SOMETHING IT
OBVIOUSLY ISN'T HOW CAN THEY
CALL THAT A TAX CUT WAS
$70 BILLION GOING TO FAMILIES
WHO PAY THE TAX?
IT IS AN AUTOMATIC WELFARE
PAYMENTS.
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING WITH
RISING PRICES.
WHY IS THAT LOOKING AT
TWO.1 PERCENT ON - - PERCENT
INFLATION AND WITH THOSE POST
PANDEMIC THAT THE OTHER HALF
INVITES INFLATION BY THE BIDEN
STUPID POLICIES.
BIDENS CRISIS EVEN WITH THOSE
THEORETICAL GAINS FROM THOSE
UNFUNDED HANDOUTS.
OF COURSE WE SHOULD HELP
STRUGGLING FAMILIES.
BUT THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS
PUT IN THE BUILDING BLOCKS OF
THE OPPORTUNITY ECONOMY TO
POWER ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND JOB
CREATION.
STRONG FAMILIES TO BUILD
STABLE FOUNDATIONS.
SCHOOL CHOICE TO HAVE LETTERS
OF OPPORTUNITY EVERY SINGLE
THING BIDEN WANTS TO DO TO
TAKE US IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
AND THEN ON DAY ONE THAT PRO-
ACT WITH FORCE MILLIONS OF
WORKERS TO TAKE MONEY OUT OF
THEIR PAYCHECKS HANDING IT
OVER TO UNIONS HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS PER YEAR HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH UNIONS THAT NOW
THEY SAY THIS IS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT A JOKE AND WITH THE
SOCIALISM SLUSH FUND AND THEN
TO HAVE KIDS TO RISE UP WITH A
LIVING MAKING YOUR TO THE
TEACHERS UNIONS THE BIGGEST
AND MOST VICIOUS OPPORTUNITY
CRUSHERS IN AMERICA.
AND TO PAY BACK FOR MORE THAN
$20 MILLION IN BRIBES I'M
SORRY DONATIONS.
AND WITH UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
AND SAYS THERE IS NO COST
REDUCTION AND THEN TO PAY FOR
THIS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
BECAUSE IT WAS IN CANADA EVEN
ACCORDING TO LEFT-WING AND
KIDS WERE WORSE OFF.
THEN WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED
PREMIUMS WERE NOT LOWER THEY
SKYROCKETED AS A DIRECT RESULT
IN AN EVEN TO PAY $10000 MORE
PER YEAR.
THAT IS A VAST EXTENSION OF
GOVERNMENT REGULATION BUT THEN
TO DESCRIBE IT AS TAX CUTS AND
MORE JOBS.
AND THE ENERGY POLICY.
AND IN FACT THE POLICY AS THEY
BACK'S PIPELINE WHILE KILLING
AMERICANS.
ON TOP OF THAT THE EXTRA
REGULATION AND THE ELECTRIC
CARS SUBSIDIES DESCRIBED AS
TAX CUTS WILL BENEFIT THE
RICH.
I'M NOT AGAINST FIGHTING
POLLUTION, QUITE THE OPPOSITE
OF I HAVE BEEN ARGUING
CONSERVATIVES LOVE NATURE BUT
WE NEED PRO- MARKET PRO
INNOVATION AND PROBLEM
AMERICA.
BUT INSTEAD THE DEMOCRATS ARE
REPLACING ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
TRUMP GAVE US IN SAUDI ARABIA
NO WONDER AMERICANS ARE NOT
PAYING AN EXTRA $20 COMPARED
TO LAST YEAR FOR A TANK OF
GAS.
SO GIVE WITH ONE HAND AND TAKE
WITH THE OTHER.
IN THE WHOLE PROGRAM IS
RIDDLED WITH STEALTH TAXES.
SO THEN THE NEW UNION TAX OR
THE HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS, GAS
PRICES AND OF COURSE DESPITE
THE LIES IN THE END EVERYONE'S
TAXES GOING UP IS A DEFICIT.
BUT OF ALL THE LIES HERE'S THE
BIGGEST ONE OF ALL.
THAT MEANT PUBLIC SUPPORT.
THESE DISGRACEFUL SLIDES TAKE
THE POLL NUMBERS TO PROVE
AMERICANS MERGE TO THE LEFT.
BUT THE ONLY POLL THAT MATTERS
THAT ACTUALLY CONFERS
LEGITIMACY ON THE GOVERNMENT
AGENDA IS THE ELECTION.
THEY HAVE NO MANDATE FOR ANY
OF THIS.
THE DEMOCRATS NEVER TALK ABOUT
SPENDING DEMOCRACY AND THEN
THAT PARTY ESTABLISHMENT TO
PRACTICALLY OVERNIGHT AND THEN
TO IMPLEMENT THE SANDERS AND
WARREN AGENDA.
STRUCTURALLY DISHONEST.